sorry couldn't be here
right
yeah me too i would have loved to attend
in person
yeah
so
uh
i'm uh quite happy to introduce our next
speaker uh braxton austin who will be
talking to us from utah and he'll talk
about archetypal analysis yeah please
so thank you very much for the
invitation and the opportunity to speak
so i'm going to talk about a couple
different aspects of archetypal analysis
and so parts of the talk are based on
joint work with rujon han who's at the
chinese university of hong kong
yi ming zhu who's
a graduate student at the university of
utah and
actually the bulk of this work is due to
him
in many of the ideas don wang was my
previous postdoc who's also at the
chinese university of hong kong but in
tenzhin
and dominique soso who's at montana
state university
okay so let me first introduce
archetypal analysis so this is an
unsupervised learning method that uses
a convex polytope to summarize
multivariate data so you're given data
there's n points in rd
and we're going to summarize this using
a convex polytope with k vertices so k
is fixed
and
the vertices we label with this capital
a
like like here
okay so we try to find the the context
polytope or equivalently the vertices of
the polytope to solve this optimization
problem so we minimize the mean squared
distance between the data
and the um
and the polytope
and we have
we're subject to the constraint that the
the polytope
or alternative the vertices are
contained in the convex hull of the
data
so i have here an illustration in two
dimensions when i choose k equal to
three so trying to approximate this data
by a triangle and
what the objective function you can see
this is the it's the distance between
the points
and the convex projection onto by the
triangle
so the the objective function is just
the sum of all these squared distances
divided by the total number of points
and
you know the triangle can't be too large
it has to be contained in the data in
the convex hole of the data
so when we solve this problem we always
label
the points at a with a star to denote
that sophomore and uh we
when speaking we say that
you know anything associated with the
optimal point set is um are their
archetype points so the points that
themselves are archetype points and the
um the contacts hold the points
is the archetype polytope or the alt
maybe the archetype polygon when the
dimensions two
okay
so that's archetypal analysis and so
this was proposed in 1994 by cutler and
bryan and they proved several results so
if k is one
then the architect points is just the
mean of the data so that's not very
surprising
when k is between one and n
uh there exists the
one the problem is
so
existence of an
minimizer
this is not unique but though that
they're gonna points at uh on the
boundary of the convex whole video
and then for k uh they're equal to n
the archetype points up uh again it's
trivial you can just take the point set
to be the day off and so the the
objective is zero okay so
k for this problem you know in practice
you should choose k between one and n
and typically k is much much uh less
than n so of course
let's summarize the data with a
small verse that's right
they also demonstrated that
archetype one
all right uh braxton you're breaking up
a little bit uh
oops it seems that the connection broke
uh for a second
yeah sorry about that uh let me let me
reconnect here can you hear me now yeah
yeah we hear you well now we just don't
see the slides yet but i think they're
coming
okay
okay
thanks did i get to say that uh
okay
okay
did i get to say that um okay so so
cutler
and brymen uh they showed that the
archetypal analysis could be
reformulated as a nonlinear least
squares problem and solved using an
alternating minimization algorithm and
this is efficient at least for small d n
and k okay so
i'll come back to this this method later
and uh you might have also heard
archetypal analysis is sometimes
referred to as principal convex hall
analysis but i won't use this language
here okay
so
i've presented this using the kind of
geometric formulation of the problem
there's also an algebraic formulation
that looks like a non-negative matrix
formulation so if i stack the uh the
data into columns of a matrix then i can
write this as the non-negative matrix
factorization problem
of um
trying to approx x by x times a b where
a and b are our column stochastic
matrices and um
[Music]
well
the sizes of a and b have to pay
attention to these uh k has what a
columns and so
x times a this ends up being the the
archetype points these are convex
combinations of the
what the columns of x
those are the archetype points and then
xab these are the projection onto the
onto the
polytope
okay so this is completely equivalent uh
to to the previous formulation
okay so you might ask um how archetypal
analysis compares to other unsupervised
learning methods that you might have
heard of um it's very closely related to
k-means so in k-means you can write it
like this
and um while you're basically comparing
this to the geometric formulation of
archetype one analysis you just remove
the convex holes right so i replace uh
i replace the convex hole with a and i
no longer have a constraint that a is
restricted a is contained in the convex
hole of data
in terms of the principal component
analysis that's used for dimensionality
reduction it's also closely related and
it's easier to see that from the
algebraic formulation
so
in you know pca you can write as um
what is also a nun as a also as a matrix
factorization problem where you as a as
orthonormal columns
and so
uh instead of using orthonormal columns
you have these non-negative matrix uh
conditions
and so in particular though if um well
if k is less than n
then uh this is also
uh
a lower rank uh approximation of the of
of x and so it's a it can also be used
as a dimensionality reduction method
so
yeah further comparison to other matrix
factorization methods
and uh clustering methods can be found
in a very nice paper by moore bin hansen
from 2012 and um so i'll refer you there
[Music]
okay so let me give a quick example just
to demonstrate this method
so i'm going to talk about um
covid19
data from early in the pandemic so this
is from may to september of 2020 and so
the data i'm going to look at are time
series and
one time series for each state plus dc
so there's 51
time series of roughly length 100
corresponding to days
and this is a nice data set because
it's very low dimensional so if you do a
pca analysis of this you find that 99 of
the variance is in just the first two
principal components so
um yes i can very easily visualize uh
where each state is
um in relation to the others and if i do
archetypal analysis with uh k equal
three vertices
i'm trying to find the optimal triangle
for this this data set um this is what i
get so i get this triangle on the left
here
and then once i have the triangle i can
kind of
transform into the archetype coordinates
right i can just
write everything in terms
of the convex combination of the
archetypes and that's what's on the
right
and so well one thing to notice is that
sometimes uh examples will be at the
vertices of the archetype
polytope and sometimes not
[Music]
but and so the nice thing about
archetypal analysis now though is that
um i think about the examples that are
near the the archetype points as kind of
extreme examples
and uh i can think about the other
examples as
convex combinations of those extreme
examples so
people like
archetype analysis because it's a little
bit more interpretable and to show that
a little bit more you know here if i
look at the time series corresponding to
states that are near the archetype
points i get these kind of yeah these
the color codes uh to different
archetype points and um
i get states like new york and new
jersey that had very high positivity
rates in the beginning of the pandemic
states like arizona that had a strong
second wave and then i had states that
have kind of uniformly uh low positivity
rates okay so i can think about the
other states as
in relationship to these extreme ones
okay so the first the first thing i want
to talk about in terms of archetype
analysis is a consistency result and
there's been many uh this discussed at
this conference already so maybe i don't
have to go into too much detail here but
i'll just say a consistency result
everything i've described so far
is i think about now is kind of discrete
archetypal analysis and to set up a
consistency result what i need to set up
a continuum version of the problem so i
think about my data now is sampled from
some distribution and then
i
solved the continuous version of the
problem to find an
archetype polytope
and then
as i sample more and more data i want to
see that
what the
the solution to the discrete problem
converges to the solution to the
continuum problem
okay and so there's of course many many
consistency results for unsupervised
learning the ones uh i have some
listed here for k-means and pca which
are the methods that are the closest
archetypal analysis and so these are
already classical
okay
so
okay so i i've set this up already so
we're going to assume that uh x of i are
iid sampled from a probability measure
mu
and um
what i want to know is uh what i'm going
to for each n i'm going to let a n
denote the optimal solution to the
archetypal analysis problem for you know
that value of n
and i want to know is there a set a
which of course should depend on u such
that a n converges to a as as n go to
goes to infinity in some sense and so
yeah to identify the limiting problem
it's useful just to write the objective
in terms of the empirical measure
so i can rewrite the objective um like
this and since you know mu and weakly
converges of mu as n goes to infinity
it's natural to consider as the limiting
problem uh this one here so i minimize
um
this
this objective
uh where i've replaced the empirical
measure with with mu
and now i've constrained the archetype
uh points to be in the convex hole the
support
of mu
okay
so indeed we do get a consistency result
uh for this yeah for this prop with this
limiting uh
solution
so
yeah
for each n
this is already known to color and
brightness the archetypal analysis
problem has at least one solution so
let's call it a of n
and our result is that um
a of n converges to a star along a
subsequence in the household distance
where a star is a solution to this
continuous
continuous version of the problem okay
so the proof of this
uh actually just uses compactness in the
triangle inequality
um
and then in addition we can we can get a
rate of convergence so if you assume
that the support of mu is convex and
actually we can relax this a little bit
but
convex is is
sufficient
then for
a large n with a high probability we
have that the
the objective evaluated at the discrete
solution
is um
[Music]
well this is always greater than the one
at the um
at the uh the continuous solution and
the difference
is um is bounded by this by this
quantity
okay so the proof of this
relies on some
results from random geometry and
dudley's inequality so it's a
concentration and quality type of result
okay
so here's an example illustrating
consistency
so i need
so i have to have a problem where
to illustrate this where i know the
solution to the the continuum problem
and so
there's not so many too many setups in
which i know that but
if mu is the uniform distribution on the
unit disk
uh then the solutions are regular k-gons
inscribed inscribed in the disk so
that's something you can show
and um so here you can see the solution
is not unique because i can rotate
the regular k-gons uh inscribed in the
disc
um and so to see the consistency result
let's see
uh
i can set k equal to three so i'm trying
to find the optimal triangle and um
i sample points from the unit disk and
solve this for a larger and larger n and
you can see that um well the maximum and
minimal angle in this triangle converge
to pi over three okay so this is
um yeah this is
what we expect from the theorem
okay so i'll say something about
probability measures with unbounded
support as well
so
uh
yeah maybe it's clear already but um if
you if you have a probability measure
with unbounded support uh then as you
sample more and more points the
constraints that
the the con the uh archetype positive is
contained in the convex hole those
points uh
is increasing uh so
you can't really con
expect a consistency result without
modifying the problem somehow
and uh the way we modify it at least at
least here is um
to introduce a variance regularization
term so we add on to the objective
function
a parameter alpha times
the variance of
the
of the archetype points themselves
so that's that's here
and um okay so for this modification
problem we also have a consistency
result uh referring to the paper for
that and we also looked at the pro the
the behavior for a large alpha so when
alpha gets large you can actually show
that all of the archetype points
converge to the mean of the data
and um and they do so at this rate and
so we illustrate this here
um
this is kind of expected i guess too
because well you expected the variance
of the archetype points to go to zero
and they should be centered at the mean
of the data and so this is this is a
very natural
unexpected result
okay
so now i want to i want to shift gears a
little bit and
talk about
algorithms for computing
archetypal analysis and the
computational complexity of them and so
this is actually one of the
the limits of of the applicability of of
age a large-scale data analysis is
because this is a very expensive problem
to solve
i have to solve this
optimization problem
this is like
i said this i presented this before as
the algebraic
version of the problem
and um cutler and brimen already
introduced this alternating minimization
algorithm where i update a and b
recursively
and so i uh
you know for fixed
a i
find
b that minimizes this problem and if you
look at this b is um well it's it's
constrained to be column stochastic so
that's this notation
and
actually this this decomposes further b
remember it's just the
it's the
convex combinations of the archetypes
that give you back the projection onto
the
polytope right so
um you can so you can think about this
as these are n k dimensional qps that
you have to solve
in this step
and then to update a a is the convex
combination of the data that gives you
the
the archetypes
and
[Music]
you can rewrite this in the same the
same form as is in step three
um
like with using some linear algebra and
so actually so here you get k n
dimensional q p's with the same these
qp's all
are all constrained
okay and so the complexity if you look
at this is a step three you have n times
the complexity of solving a k
dimensional quadratic program and in
step four you have k times the
complexity of solving
and uh concerning qps
okay
and so there's been a lot of work um
looking at accelerating aaa and some of
these focused on improving the
optimization methods to solving the
quadratic programs
so we will find many different
optimization methods here
and then
there's also
previous work on the inherent
complexity so
some of this is is empirical and some of
it's more theoretical um relying on
either random projections or core sets
okay so our approach complements these
uh methods
and we combine two approaches to reduce
the inherent complexity of the problem
so the first thing we do is we reduce
the data dimensionality via randomized
low rank approximations we think about
this as kind of data preprocessing which
is reducing the dimensionality and then
the second thing is we reduce the
representation carbonality by
approximating the convex holes of the
data
so this is an acceleration step for step
four
and so both of these approaches i'll
show off theoretical guarantees
and what's nice is that you can
combine this approach with the above you
know the improved qp optimization
methods here or the um these kind of
corset methods here
um
yeah if you want to further speed this
up
so these these can be
combined with the previous work
okay
so first i'll talk about the
data
dimensionality reduction part of this
and so the main idea here is i want to
find a low dimensional representation on
x tilde for x and okay so the first
thing i'll say is you should use a
truncated singular value decomposition
and uh okay so the problem here is that
it's expensive if the dimension and the
number of points n are large
so it's order of dn times the minimum of
dnn
and so you can use an approximated
truncated cv svd so that's that's what
we do
um
so if i um
we can show that if okay so if you
denote the optimal objective value of
the problem by op x
and we let
x tilde be the
this is a rank p approximation of x
and it's uh
up to a factor of two so here's here's
the definition of xp what this two rank
p approximation
means
[Music]
and then i'm going to let x tilde just
be the um
the part of xp in the in the up
coordinates okay so that's that's the x
total
if
using this x tilde i solve the
archetypal analysis problem i need to
know the solution to that by a tilde b
total
what we what we show is that um
well the objective function
evaluated it for this a tilde b tilde
is um
[Music]
well it's less than or equal to the the
best value you can obtain plus eight
times the
the p plus one singular value
okay and so in particular if my original
data was
rank
p
then this would be um an exact
approximation right
okay
so how do you obtain uh this this x
tilde p
and you can use um
you can use ideas from randomized block
cryolog method so this is this is
introduced by moscow and muscle
and the idea here is to generate random
random matrices and form a krylov
subspace and then went to a qr
decomposition and you do an svg there
and um well in the end you
you cleverly put the matrices together
to get an x to the p
okay and so uh the muscle and muscle's
result is that this xp tilda
obtained like this is is in fact a two
rank p approximation to x with high
probability okay so this is the method
that we use and uh the nice thing is
that this x tilde can be computed
uh
with this complexity so remember before
i had a
a min
of d and then here so now i've replaced
this by log of n e
okay
all right so let's talk about the second
the second reduction
and this is the reduction in the
representation cardinality
so the main idea here is to use the
extreme points of x as a dictionary so
remember there's
the archetype points i only have to look
at the boundary of the convex whole of
the data
so
yeah so
if i only knew the extreme points of of
the data then um i could solve the
problem but the problem is of course
that is expensive to compute the extreme
points of a high dimensional um points
at
and so
the solution then is to select a few
important extreme points for the
representation and so i'll say what
important is and then i'll say how again
we compute these
so what we can show is that
if you were to somehow be able to choose
a subset of the data so x of t is a
subset of the columns of the matrix x
[Music]
if i could somehow choose a subset of
the columns so that the convex hall of
those columns compared to the convex
whole of the columns of the all of x
is small in the household measurement
uh metric then um
and i
with using those
so that subs of the columns i solved the
reduced a optimization problem
so here x t replaces x in the usual
problem
then the optimal value here
is less than or equal to 1 plus epsilon
times the optimal value for the original
problem
okay
so let me say
first how we how we select this
this subset
t
so you can find x of t
by random projections and so this is
uh these are ideas
from graham and oberman
and the idea is that
points that are more likely to be
sampled in random projections are also
more important in some sense and so you
know very roughly what i do is i i
choose you i id sample random vectors uh
from the sphere
and i looked at the projection of the
columns of x onto onto those vectors
and then i um
well i basically keep the columns of x
so that that
obtain this largest projected value uh
very frequently
okay so you have to be careful about the
number of the number of um columns that
you keep but okay that's that's the
basic idea
and
uh with the theorem what we were able to
show is that if i um
if i choose uh m large enough so m is
the number of uh random vectors that i
that i choose
uh then
the distance in the house or metric
between this chosen subset x of t and x
satisfies exactly the kind of the
the the bound that i needed as an
assumption in the previous theorem
and so yeah here you see the cursive
dimensionality up here
okay and so okay
all right so i'm going to put these
ideas together now and this is going to
be
the
this is our approximate archetypal
analysis method
so
the first thing i do is i use
these ideas of moscow and moscow to
find
a reduced dimension
data x tilde
then i apply this random projection
method x to the to find x tilde t so
this is a subset of the columns of x
tilde
and then now i finally solved this
reduced archetypal analysis problem
where i have x tilde t
here
okay
and so
this this problem of course
looks just like the original problem the
original archetypal analysis problem so
when i say you know any any method that
you use to speed up the optimization for
this can be applied in this step here
okay
and then from this a tale of each other
i can get back my um my solution
okay so what we can prove about this
this approximate archetypal uh method
is that um
is the following
so
uh under some assumptions okay i'll just
say that um well the um
the solution that we get till the beat
till the
uh it they is
uh startilda
the objective value for those uh
for those matrices is less than or equal
to okay so it's a factor of one plus
epsilon times the best value you're
gonna get plus eight times the um
the p plus first singular value of the
data
okay and so the upshot of all this
is that um
well p and q are small so i didn't say
what q is but if p is the intrinsic
dimension of the data and q think about
q is like the um
it's more or less the size of the um the
number of points in t
so if p and q are small then
[Music]
the complexity of this this method is
going to be small so in other words yeah
x x is approximately if x is
approximately r and has
um
most of the curvature concentrated on a
small subset of extreme points then the
overall complexity of this
approximation
is going to be low
okay
so i'll conclude
by showing some numerical examples
so here we apply the approximate
archetypal analysis
to first
s p 500 stock data so we have about 2
000 days
of
of stock data for 500 uh 572 stocks
and we look at the the cumulative log
returns of these datas as a time series
and we're going to compare three
different methods one method is the
method i just described the approximate
archetypal analysis method one method is
if i actually just computed the svd and
applied
regular vanilla archetypal analysis and
then one is um using the there's an r
package called archetypes uh for this
and we're going to repeat these
experiments many times and i'll i'll
report you know the average behavior so
the first thing i want to say okay so
these are some
archetypes for
different instances of the method and so
you can see that the archetypes are
stable
in this method
you know the same the same time series
are picked over and over again
um and uh if you compare let's see first
the um the timing of these three methods
uh
you find that the approximate method is
much better than the other two methods
i think this is a factor of 60 better
than using um the the original
uh method with with the singular value
decomposition
and what maybe what's surprisingly
what is surprising is that um
well of course the approximate
archetypal analysis can't so if i look
at the residual
uh the approximate archetypal analysis
can't do better than the than the
original archetypal analysis but it does
much better than the r package their
package does in another approximation
and um so this is both faster and gives
you better results than the our package
okay and so we also try to justify that
the assumptions that we made
uh in our reductions
are
are
hold for this data set so indeed the
intrinsic dimension of the data
is is pretty small
and um
what the
the um
uh
okay so and then we looked at here's the
scatter plot of the reduced uh
representation with the with the
archetypes as well
okay and so as a second example
um
yeah
here's um we look at 3000
images each image is 150 by 150 pixels
rgb pixels and we run
archetypal analysis on this and so this
example is now big enough that we
couldn't compare to like the r back edge
or
the simpler method and um
okay so here is um it took about 600
seconds to run
[Music]
this oh sorry so about six minutes
to run this
on a standard laptop
and
so these are the uh 10 archetypes uh
that we get and so
these um yeah these account for 44 of
the total variance of the data set and
they um
they are very different images they were
kind of extreme examples within the data
set so they're
you can interpret maybe the other images
in terms of these ones
[Music]
okay so that's what i want to say about
that
and so just just to conclude so for
boundary distributions we identified a
continuum problem continuum version of
the archetypal analysis
method and a consistency result
including the convergence rate for
unbounded distributions we introduced a
variance regularized problem and
established a consistency result there
and then
and then finally we devised an
approximate algorithm for large scale
archetypal analysis which enjoys
theoretical guarantees so if you have
any questions i'm happy to take them
thanks
thanks brooks
[Applause]
all right questions
thank you braxton very nice talk
uh so
i have a question regarding you know the
choice of k
so
i mean if k is uh you know
much less than d
i would expect that uh
you're still doing a k component on a
yes k component pca
on top of
the archetypal uh
problem into the hyperplane or something
like that
first question if you want and the
second question is
so if in the end
so in in the application
what you want to get is uh you know the
the limit
the limiting behavior according to the
measure mu
uh along which you are uh you know you
are taking the samples like the
the images or the stock
so would it make sense to
not
you know disregard maybe big n and
taking just
a few examples of what you have so do
not explore all the data
also if you know if you have maybe k is
small
if k is small maybe you don't need to to
use all your examples maybe using just
randomly
uh you know in function of k
maybe you get the same statistical
properties or something like that
yeah so yeah thanks for the question so
yeah it's true choosing um choosing k in
this method is uh
a little bit tricky and it's trickier
than principle component analysis
because
uh
what when you when you choose
when you change the value of k like if i
increase k by one the the old archetypes
change right
and so this is the beautiful property in
in pca that yeah so this does not carry
over here
uh but you're right the observation that
um
for k very small
uh
we expect that uh
yeah the the
the
arc
type uh polytope is contained in the in
the
in the vca space uh in the subspace that
the pca gives you
uh or at least at least is close to it
um
yeah and you're commenting about
um
throwing out unimportant data points
that i mean that's uh
i think i think uh
this is
somewhat what we do when we compute x of
t right
this um when we when we reduce the the
representation cardinality we are
we're trying to throw away
uh points that are kind of in the
interior of the convex all of the data
in fact more than that maybe we will
even throw away extreme points if they
um
if they don't have large curvature so i
i kind of gloss over this a little bit
but um
yeah there's a interpretation in terms
of the
the points that we keep in terms of
curvature
and um
yeah we throw those away too if they
don't have large scripture
thanks braxton
uh are there any further questions
just a brief question on my side is are
there some estimates on how far is this
from pca let's say when k is small right
case three how far is it from the plane
could one obtain some estimates on that
yeah i think that's a nice problem i
haven't seen estimates like that
yeah we're a little bit kind of uh
running late so we're gonna
stop here let's thank braxton again
and we come back at the quarter to
11.